what are the most common complaints that
you're hearing from the women that you
coach about the men that they're dating
what are the issues that they're coming
up against most frequently
um
I suppose they're not ready
they don't want to commit
I want something meaningful I want
something that's actually going to go
somewhere and this person is just kind
of stringing me along or they can't seem
to they a lot of people wouldn't frame
it like this person stringing me along
because that kind of there's a hard
thing to admit but they may say this
person keeps saying they're not ready
and they're just not quite there yet and
they're not sure and so I think the
indecisiveness of men and the inability
to actually
commit is that's gotta be
the top one I would say well that would
run counter a little bit to a lot of
what you hear about on the internet
which would be that most men are
struggling to find a date that they
can't get attention from women that
women are actually looking for attention
from the top man as much as possible and
in my experience this you know I've
stood on the front door of a thousand
events and met a million people across
my entire life
you know 18 to 21 year old guys and
girls aren't exactly known for their
maturity especially not in the UK
especially not when they're drunk and
yet in my experience
most of the girls even at that age were
looking for maybe it wasn't a
particularly mature form of commitment
but they were looking for commitment
they're looking for a guy that they
could hold hands with and go away to a
little summer vacation with and do
Christmas markets in December
it seems to me that a lot of the
a lot of the concerns that guys have
around what women want and the issues
that they're facing
don't seem to match up massively what
are the concerns that guys have I think
that the big ones are that they're not
going to be found attractive that
they're going to be seen as creepy if
they approach them if they try to do
online dating that they're not going to
be responded to if they try to approach
them in the real world that they're
going to be seen as some metoo Predator
that she is going to trade up because
there is an endless hierarchy of guys
that could fly her out to Dubai there's
some shake on the other side of
Instagram that's going to dhammer and
put her on a five-star flight to to take
her out to Dubai and uh that you know
this is this is the world that we live
in now that girls have more
opportunities than ever before because
it's been afforded by social media which
means that the top few guys are going to
eat and everybody else is going to
starve I sympathize I with guys on all
of those things I I feel I really it
touches me when you say it because I I
think that there is
it's a really hard thing
for anyone to feel invisible
and and what's more to feel like even if
I'm briefly visible I will become
invisible again the moment this person
comes across someone with more
and when I
hear that
I come to two immediate conclusions one
is
choose well
choose someone as a man who truly
is you know one of the phrases Audrey
used all the time when we were dating
and getting to know each other she kept
saying as a philosophy for her life
I just believe in chasing the right
things
that you will always be kind of not
punished but life will always like give
you its comeuppance if you chase the
wrong things
and you'll always have to end up at some
point circling back to the right thing
it's just when you just decide to do it
and
I've come to look at that as like one of
my key mantras for life I look at all
the time am I chasing the right thing or
the wrong thing here and I think that a
lot of guys are struggling because
they're chasing the wrong thing
um
they themselves you know it's
there is an entitlement among a lot of
guys that
I
I should have this
and it we the funny thing about dating
is that we end up accusing each other of
exactly the thing that we're doing
and we really hate the other side for
doing it
but it is exactly what we're doing it's
one Community saying it's disgraceful
how shallow they are
that I have to be a certain height for
them to even pay attention to me
and meanwhile they're going
why don't I have the top one percent of
women
you're going what are you talking about
it's literally you just did exactly the
same thing you just said there was a top
one percent and you're not interested in
the rest
that there is a hypocrite on both sides
there is a hypocrisy there
that I really struggle with and I think
the more
we can get to a point where we go what
are the counter-cultural compromises
that I am willing to make in order to
actually live a happy life
not
a life that everyone else says is so
impressive
not a life where I finally go look I
made it I'm dating the cheerleader
a life that's actually making you happy
because you've you've selected for the
right things
what counter-cultural compromises will
you have to make for that
we talked earlier about because I know
for me I'm all about looking at that on
both sides
we talked earlier about women who
might
say well I want to date someone who's at
my level
and I want to go well let's redefine
what you class as your level do you mean
your level for kindness
your level for generosity your level for
empathy
your level for being loyal
or do you mean your level of income
because the things I said first will
make you far happier
this thing doesn't really matter
but you've told yourself it matters now
could you make a compromise that goes
against the grain
because that that is what if if we go
online and we look at all of these
communities is everyone arguing to me
there's from the outside because I don't
I'm not deep in these things but I know
I hear it's like I hear second hand all
the time so you can always correct me if
I'm getting it wrong on what people are
saying out there
but when I look at it I feel like so
much debate is being had at the macro
level
of here's how men are here's how women
are and hear all the things we can't
stand about the cultural norm right now
and
when I look at that I'm like this feels
to me
like in if it was the business
equivalent
it's like I want to start a sandwich
shop
and I spend all my time
watching the news
and the economy
and the macro statistics
and saying this is why I shouldn't start
a sandwich shop
this is why you can't start a sandwich
shop today
look at it I'm watching the news all day
and it's terrible or you know the
banking system is going to collapse soon
you know that right no point starting a
sandwich shop now or constantly arguing
about politics and who's in government
oh it's the Democrat oh it's not
business friendly oh you don't want to
be in California it's not business
friendly right I'm not going to start a
business in California like does does
that mindset and I have always one of
the reasons that I've always loved
studying things from a place of
curiosity and that's what you do you
you're facet you're a curious person
who's fascinated by
how things work and why things are
happening so I get the that part I
understand
but when people are complaining
constantly about the macro of it all and
that becomes their excuse
I always just think do you realize that
your life changes by what you do in the
micro if you're a woman and you're
saying men are always intimidated by me
I say in the macro you're a hundred
percent right
that there is an awful lot of men if
you're a high earner if you're a high
status if you've done a lot in your life
oh there's going to be a lot of men who
are intimidated by you that's 100 true
so I would never want to invalidate that
but on the micro
if you're telling me that men are always
intimidated by you
something's going wrong
well who's the common denominator
between all of these men
right now you could say men the the
gender is the common denominator is men
men have a problem with there's none of
my female friends have a problem with
this men have a problem with this but
but I look at that and I go
there is a way to either you're going
for a certain kind of guy all the time
or you're going in
with that as your kind of power and that
is your value and that's the thing you
talk about all the time no one wants to
go out with a rich person who talks
about how much money they have
no one
no one wants to go out with a celebrity
who talks about how famous they are
you you want to go out with someone who
has a conversation with you and gets to
know you and is interested in you and is
impressed by you
right that's one of the most attractive
things in the world is you go on it like
people should go on a date asking
themselves how could I be impressed by
this person
and if you do that and there was a
writer friend of mine who used to work I
think he wrote for The Hollywood
Reporter or someone but he used to say
when he would interview celebrities the
goal for himself so that he could write
a good piece was always to go
because he didn't care he'd been doing
it so long it was for him it was like
just another person coming through the
door with a movie it long past the point
of having any novelty for him
but he would say could by the end of
this interview
could I get to a place of feeling
grateful for having been here
and he knew that the key to accessing
that gratitude was fine feeling like by
the end of the time with that person
they had taught him something they had
given him some kind of Life perspective
or told him their story in a way that
made him feel like wow
I'm actually really grateful I got to
sit with this person he said if I could
achieve that gratitude I knew that the
article I would write
would convey that I knew it would be a
good piece
I think that we could approach dating
that way but so many people go on a date
and it's like here's what's impressive
about me
here's why here's here's why you should
feel a little intimidated by me instead
of going how can I how can I show I'm
impressed by you or how can I show that
there's something about you that just
wow that's really interesting or that I
have a unique understanding of You by
the end of the date that's super
attractive it makes someone feel seen
that taking go back to our example if
you're someone who let's say is real you
have a job that intimidates people
you also have immense leverage in being
able to reverse that
by the way that you are on a date with
someone and so that to me is always
for me on the front lines of dating
where I'm constantly helping people to
actually go out there and find love
I always want to say to them forget the
news
look at what's what are the things you
could do
to transform your dating life and it's
it's wild how much you can do to
transform your dating life and it
doesn't matter what's going on out there
there's this phrase that a doctor friend
of mine used when it came to diseases in
hospitals he said statistics don't
matter to the individual if you've if
you get a one in a thousand disease
it doesn't matter to you that is one in
a thousand you're you have the disease
but I actually from a dating perspective
like to put a positive spin on that
regardless of how Grim things seem out
there
the statistic doesn't matter to the
individual if you as an individual learn
how to be more proactive in your love
life you learn how to be a beautiful
presence on a date you learn how to
attract someone those statistics are not
going to be the primary thing affecting
your love life we'll get back to talking
to Matthew in one minute but first I
need to tell you about a product I've
used every single day for three years
now to help support my health and my
nutrition and that's ag1 by athletic
greens even with the best of intentions
I don't get enough fruit and vegetables
in my diet I don't know if anybody does
and ag-1 helps to fill those nutritional
gaps and just make me feel more
confident that every single day I'm
covering all of my bases ag1 is a
life-changing nutritional habit it's got
75 vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients including a
multivitamin multi-mineral pre and
probiotic green superfood blend and more
that all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet it is the
most comprehensive all-in-one daily
powder that I've ever tried I always
wondered why guy is like Tim Ferriss and
Andrew hubman and Joe Rogan were talking
about it and after trying pretty much
every other drink on the market I can
see why it is the best tasting and most
comprehensive that I've ever found also
there is a 90-day money-back guarantee
so you can buy it and try it for 89 days
and if you do not like it they will give
you your money back head to
athleticgreens.com wisdom to get a
Year's free supply of vitamin D 5 free
travel packs and more that's
athleticgreens.com
[Music]
wisdom thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks